so now we're seeing a pattern what is
that pattern the pattern is what that
these individuals who are from Christian
background or Christian majority
countries you want to call them migrants
or not migrants whatever you want to
label them who are keep attacking kids
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana in the
country of Norway click on the link and
donate now for the sake of Allah subhana
waala brothers and sisters and dear
friends we all have heard the story of
the innocent 11-year old girl who was
attacked and stabbed eight times so much
so that the blood that was splatted on
her mom was uh seen as if the mother got
um stab injuries but she didn't it was
actually the blood that splatt it on her
subh so it was so horrific and we guys
know Subhan Allah that um a brother
called Abdullah may Allah bless and
preserve him protected him a Pakistani
migrant who ran to the rescue which our
religion teaches why the prophet
Muhammad peace upon him said the lowest
form of Iman faith is what to move a
harmful thing from the roads I jumped on
him hold the hand in which was him
having a knife and he just put him down
on the floor and just hold him and kick
the knife away from him and then a
couple of more people joined as well and
we just F him until the police came it
took like maybe 3 to 4 minutes police
arrived and then they just took him into
the CER and the child just like all my
colleagues they give him first a and in
the middle police came and they just
gave the first an object well in this
matter it was not a harmful object
inanimate object it was a actual harmful
evil individual who wanted to harm
11year old so he enacted this very thing
that the prophet Muhammad PE told us
it's very ironic isn't it it's very
bizarre because you look at uh the first
individual Axel who's the one who killed
three innocent young girls to kids
children Subhan Allah who was from a
majority Christian country his family
was churchgoing individuals and now
you've got this individual who is from
Romania who the population is nearly I
would say well close to uh you 100%
Christians 85% of them being Orthodox
Christians Subhan Allah and there's
different denominations so now we're
seeing a pattern what is that pattern
the pattern is what that these
individuals who are from Christian
background or Christian majority country
countries you want to call them migrants
or not migrants whatever you want to
label them who are keep attacking kids
now the movement of Tommy Robertson the
scumbag or should we call him t a Tomy
yes who was being sponsored a patriot
who was working for another country um
for that matter who had the slogan save
our kids now the question that we all
need to ask is save your kids from who
save your kids from what where did this
propaganda come from because if you look
at it the one of the worst atrocities
that happened in the last decade when it
came to child sex abuse was reported by
the nbcc and was called the Glasgow 7 if
I'm not mistaken for that matter is of
these individuals white middle-aged men
should we say and who were doing what
giving these kids drugs cocaine alcohol
and even tried to stuff one in a
microwave yes one of the worst scandals
that we saw in the UK but it's okay and
then we have and then we have Lucy letby
who Lucy letby who killed eight babies
and tried to attempt to kill six or some
say 10 Subhan Allah but it seems that
for the far right it's okay because as
long as one of their own is doing the
crime in this heinous crime they have no
problem they can't fight anybody but if
it's a migrant it's such a sickening
idea the fact that you are okay with
your own kind committing atrocities like
that and we by the way we know what the
um the majority of the individuals who
pedophilia around the world is we know
what what the their race and background
is it's as if they're basically saying
we have no problem that's why you don't
see Tommy Robinson the Tel Aviv Tommy
Robinson who is talking about this it's
so sickening that they have a problem
with their uh other individuals from
different backgrounds or race or
religion committing this H his crimes
now the question is what now we as
individuals we need to look at this and
say hold on a second we are actually
worried because now this is becoming a
pattern individuals who are from
predominantly Christian backgrounds are
for some odd reason keep attacking kids
and children so yes save our kids I'm
going to say for all of us for that
matter because it seems like the biggest
threat to our kids is what if we're
going to go down that root is what from
predominantly Christian background
individuals or church gr individuals or
should we say the majority of those ones
who have who've been abusing sexually
abusing the biggest scandals have been
what from the Catholic Church from the
priests let's be uh very honest that
matter those who have been abusing
children who been who white middle-aged
men so this slogan of save our kids it's
correct it's just placed in the wrong
place and the propaganda is being used
when the very individuals that are
committing this atrocious acts are
Caucasian individuals who have a Western
slch Christian background now of course
we don't blame Christianity for this
matter definitely not but there is a
point to be made and that is that
brother sisters a Muslim Pakistani
migrant was the one who came to the
rescue the far right are gone dead
silent the God's timing is amazingly
perfect what happened with Axel sad subh
sorry what happened with the killing of
those three innocent girls and men
injured and now another weird old
criminal individual who came and again
we can't blame Romanians this is
prophetic I've got Romanian neighbors
myself lovely individuals when I wake up
in the morning they greet me peace
loving for that matter yeah nothing to
do with their religion nothing to do
with them being Romanian yes so the
point is what brother sisters it is a
propaganda tool that has been used to
divert our attention from what's going
in Palestine that's exactly what's
happened the bastard Tel Aviv Tommy
Robinson the scumbag as you can see
who's having holidays while his uh
little foot soldiers are carrying
attacks on innocent individuals so I
challenge anyone from the far right to
come and debate me in Speakers Corner I
there any of you flipping cowards yes
you flipping baldheaded clown yes I'm
talking to you sitting in your flipping
basement flipping overweight watching
pornography yes come to Speakers Corner
and debate me on this topic that's all I
have to say inshallah and a big salute
to brother Abdullah because you enacted
what Islam teaches you but oh no the far
is going to say what why do you have to
bring his religion into it for some odat
reason when he when a Muslim does
something good don't bring his religion
into it but when he does something bad
it's definitely his religion you double
standard hypocritical scumbags that's
what you are and in to next time brother
and
sisters maybe I will get a chance to
inshah interview brother Abdullah it
would be nice to reach out to him
inshallah to um speak to him inshallah
and find out exactly what happened on
that day where he put his life on the
risk on the line to save that poor
little girl and that's what every single
Muslim is taught that if you save one
soul in if you save the whole of
humanity that's all I want to
say Islam net is raising funds to
establish a mid and community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support every person who prays there
every kid that learns about Islam every
youngster that memorized Quran all of
this and so much more can be on your
scale of Good Deeds click the link and
donate what you can and share the video
for even extra reward